foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight please we're gonna censored
Lynch the Grinch strikes again and takes
40 000 as union members with him rail
strikes cause chaos across Britain and
there's more to come I'll talk to a
militant Union boss about the strikes
that are canceling Christmas
the truth or their truth the California
musclingers to take a name of their
families the palace and the press and
the Netflix wine-a-thon everyone who
calls Dr sells tonight the reality show
at a flame with Prince Harry reveals to
me how she's now been airbrushed from
his history
[Music]
one of the most beautiful classical
pieces of music ever written should we
now be boycotting it and Tchaikovsky
because it was written by a Russian
composer I'll speak to the Ukrainian
culture Minister asking us all to do
just that
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to pairs Morgan accent so
Britain isn't feeling very festive this
Christmas it's more a case of no no no
than ho ho ho fills up we're living in a
country in constant decline war in
Europe has brought tragedy to our
doorsteps and rocketing bills to our
doormats families are being paid to turn
off their power just to prevent
blackouts millions of people can barely
afford to keep it switched on in the
first place eye watering inflation is
taking more money out of people's
pockets with every passing month
Supermarket prices are soaring dusters
were sucked into what could be an
historic recession now austerity is
looming compounded by a mismanaged
brexit that's bringing disasters rather
than dividends and far from providing
answers and Leadership our politics is
paralyzed by Perpetual chaos five
education secretaries four Chancellor
three prime ministers in a year can
conservative parties been in power for
12 years and even to many of his own
supporters it now looks punch drunk out
of ideas and on the ropes and as a
result trade unions can smell blood like
vultures around a rotten carcass and
with a wave of winter strikes worse than
anything we've seen in many decades
they're trying to land a knockout blow
make the Grinch Lynch of the rmt is the
flag bearer for Britain strike chaos 40
000 of Israel workers are walking out
this week they refused to be interviewed
by me today as he has done for many
weeks following a series of cantankerous
car crash interviews he conducted this
morning we found out why he's got so
camera shy
you are robbing them of their income for
the coming year many of them are saying
they're going to go bust
well we're not targeting Christmas this
it isn't Christmas yet Richard I don't
know when your Christmas starts but mine
starts on Christmas Eve we understand
the anger that's caused by the
disruption of the of the stoppages of
course
um but we are getting a lot of support
from the public we continue to get
messages people continue to visit our
picket lines and what businesses ought
to be asking the government is why are
they subsidizing this strike you're just
parroting the most right-wing stuff that
you can get hold of on behalf of the
establishment and it's about time you
showed some partiality towards your
listeners and to Working Class People in
this country
because a lot of Working Class People
have been directly impacted by these
strikes Mick Lynch hasn't got any
answers it's not right wing it's not an
establishment cover-up public support
for these Stripes is evaporating because
people are angry and they're angry
because it feels like Britain is falling
apart we're all being held to Ransom Now
by these union bosses nothing seems to
work anymore bus drivers postal workers
nurses Highway controllers are all set
to strike this week the Army is
preparing to cover border security at
airports taxi drivers should be used to
cover ambulance strikes over Christmas
Britain has become a paralyzed laughing
stock and we all deserve better we've
had enough of them we have all this
chaos of this decline we've certainly
had enough I think of the people who
have been putting us in this position
and his time as a country we started
fighting back well in the moment I'll
speak to the former assistant general
secretary of the rmt's chief edley
because it's the current one won't come
on but first the boss of the Republican
commercial service union marks which
represents border Force workers who are
striking over Christmas Mr savarka just
before I came on air tonight
um interesting development in the nurses
strike where the UK's Chief nurse has
actually challenged now the position of
the RCN the main nurses Union warning
that patients lives are being put at
risk by these strikes which are being
planned by nurses that is the first I
would say dramatic
example of a Workforce now realizing the
dangers of these strikes what do you say
to that
well I'm not here to talk about the
Health Service peers other than to say I
fully support the right of all nurses
to take industrial action as I do all
workers because the blame for all of
this should be squarely laid at the
government's door they've caused the
cost of living crisis they've doubled
our mortgages
they've sat back and done nothing
and what we're doing in trade unions now
when members of our unions are voting in
my case with an 86 percent majority to
strike
is saying we're going on strike because
it cannot be right that the government
is cutting everybody's pay in real terms
and we deserve a decent pay raise okay
so you don't talk about nurses but what
the chief nurse of this country is
saying is if this industrial action
happens with the nurses and I accept
it's not your direct responsibility but
if it happens if they go on strike she
is worried that patience Lies We put at
risk in other words people may die
are you comfortable with that that
industrial action could lead to people
in this country dying
well I put the blame squarely on the in
the in the government's court because
the nurse's leaders have made it clear
they would not proceed with industrial
action if the government agreed to talk
about their pay that's an entirely
reasonable position and the people who
are worried should be contacting Richie
sunac and Jeremy Hunt and Steve Barkley
they have the power to stop all of these
strikes by being prepared to negotiate
on pay they should do that in the Health
Service they should do that for the
people I represent in the Civil Service
40 000 of whom by the way peers are
using food banks 45 000 of whom who work
with the government claim inward
benefits because they are the Working
Poor if the government says we won't
talk about pay industrial action is the
only last resort that we now have left
and that is why members are voting in
huge numbers to go on strike they'd
rather not go on strike but frankly if
the government are not prepared I do
believe do you believe as a as a
starting point of principle for any
negotiation that everyone who's
currently going on strike are about to
go on strike should get a pay rise at
least equivalent to inflation if not
more nurses want 19 for example should
they all get at least the equivalent of
inflation
yeah my opinion is every working person
every woman and man has the right when
they go to work to ensure their living
standards don't drop if your pay rise is
less than a rate of inflation you are
having a pay cut in real terms and for
the people I'm representing we've had
that for 10 consecutive years now with
this cost of living crisis the two
percent we're being given when inflation
at 11 is not only the lowest payoffer
anywhere in the economy it is frankly
absurd and the government know that and
that's why the industrial action has
taken place you see I think it's
perfectly possible to have a lot of
sympathy for everyone is going on strike
because cost of living crisis is very
real and is really impacting people it's
also possible to see there is clearly a
joined up concerted effort Now by union
leaders to get together to bring this
government down and it's also clear that
if actually you all genuinely believe
that all these Strikers should get all
your members from everyone should all
get at least in line with inflation as
pay Rises this country will go bankrupt
now I can and I would add a fourth point
it's also possible to believe we're in
this miserable position because the
government's been hopeless all those
things can be true but your
responsibility is surely to get a fair
and balanced pay rise for your members
without actually imperiling the very
economic stability of the countries and
I mean why would you want to behave as
badly as you claim the government's been
behaving
well I certainly agree that the
government's hopeless and the sooner
they go the better
my job is not to bring down the
government but it is to get the
government to recognize that when forty
thousand of his own Workforce the people
who work in job centers for example have
to claim the benefits they administer
something is wrong and when you've had
10 years of pay raises less than
inflation and you get to a cost of
living crisis if the government is
saying that's tough then we have to do
something about it now we want a 10 pay
raise that's our claim but what we've
said to the government is if they are
prepared to say now they have money they
will put money on the table we've made
it clear we will get into negotiations
with them about how much that is and how
it's distributed their answer is not a
penny will be put on the table therefore
all we can do is either sit back and
accept that our members will have the
worst Christmas in living memory many of
them not only claiming
um benefits and using food banks but
struggling to feed themselves okay let
me ask you look you keep referencing
people who you haven't used food banks
I've heard this a lot in this debate how
if you don't mind me asking you actually
I don't care if you mind or not how much
do you earn
well I own considerably less than your
peers
what I earn is a matter of public record
my salary is 97 000 pounds set
democratically by my union and what are
the what are the perks on top of that
there are no perks in a couple now so
your total remuneration is 97 000. I
received 97 000 pounds uh that is a
public record my pay raise every year is
linked to the raise that our members get
and the question isn't here
you want like a a ten thousand pound pay
rise for yourself
no I uh I have accepted in when our
members received zero percent I received
zero percent yeah but right now you say
you want you want to pay rise in line
with inflation for your members that
would be at the moment around 10 so you
would get about 10 grand you accept that
no I don't accept that no because if we
were to achieve a 10 pay raise in my own
Union for three consecutive years the
most senior staff in the union took no
pay raise whatsoever and donated their
money back to the union strike fund so
would you do that in this eventuality
would you refuse well I'm more than
happy to say if our members got a 10 pay
raise I would happily forgo that and put
it in the strike fund because our
members who pay benefits who keep the
borders open and keep the courts running
and the prisons running orpu appears
their average wage is 23 000 pounds a
year the government has given them two
percent I don't think you believe two
percent is realistic it's less than
anyone else is being offered it's less
than the 6.2 percent average earnings in
Britain it's less than any other part of
the public sector has been offered up to
10 years of pay kids so what we're doing
now by going on strike is saying to the
government there they put money on the
table or they should take the blame for
the disruption that is coming and more
than that and I'm quite happy to say it
on your show so yes of course we are
talking to union leaders in every other
Union and there's about 30 whose members
are also doing the same thing because if
the government is the cause of
everyone's problems then it's only right
that we work together to try to get the
government to see sense okay I believe
servants deserve a pay raise but so do
rail workers train drivers lecturers
postal workers every working man and
woman deserves to go to work to be
better off each year not get real yeah I
listen I can agree with the sentiment
except we are in the middle of an
unbelievable financial crisis where if
we give everybody the same rate of
inflation as a pay rise the country goes
bust which is completely irresponsible
so there has to be a meeting ground
which does not involve everyone getting
uh inflation because if they do we can't
afford it so that's where we are and it
can be down to incompetent government it
can be down to everything but I just
don't think the union leaders Holding
Out for that as their yardstick are
doing the country any favors either but
go leave it there well um
every Union has made it clear they'll
get into talks if more money is on the
table and the government okay
I've heard you loud and clear I
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much indeed joining me now is the former
assistant general secretary of the rmt
Steve heady we wanted to have the
current one uh Mick the Grinch but he uh
was not available
well quite simply because the payoffer
has been made over two years it's five
percent this year and four percent next
year is in real terms a 12 pay cut
because inflation's 12 this year and at
the very best is forecast they fall to
eight percent next year it could be
higher than eight percent
in Scotland Pierce I don't know if you
know about this but until it's been done
in Scotland where people got five
percent plus a 750 Point bonus and that
was a one-year deal
and there's going to be no job cuts and
there's going to be no extra shifts work
extra nights or extra weekends so that's
where the rnt are basically right there
having this battle which I fully support
the right there defendant jobs defendant
safety on the railway and demanding uh
the people catch up
with the inflation that's been driven by
excessive profits been driven by oil
prices being driven by food prices it's
not been driven by wages
and people need a pay raise do you think
the negotiations between union leaders
and the government should be done in a
civil way
foreign
I think that um when when you've got
ministers making it clear that
they've they've not got anything they
offer but they're still you know uh
saying that they want talks well what is
the point of having talked so if you've
got nothing they offer surely the point
of having talks is they reach a
compromise no I think that um
there's been eight weeks no when the rnt
hasn't been on Strike Back Time could
have been used and productively by the
government to get around the table
I mean I I think that deal in Scotland
is a terrible thing by the way that's my
personal opinion but our members are
accepted and I accept that so if it's
good enough for people up in Scotland
why is it not good enough for people
turn here and I would kind of reiterate
Mark's point about the the nurses these
are people that haven't been on strike
in 106 years and the government they're
even refusing they talk to them at all
about paid now all this happens in
Scotland is the Scottish government and
I'm no fan of the SMP the Scottish
government said we'll talk to you about
paying and they call the strike off
the reason I asked you about civility
you know you want to get in the room
with people I accept you're not the
leader anymore but you were suspended by
the rmt because you said and I remember
you doing this and I remember feeling
incense when you did it that you would
throw a party if Boris Johnson died of
coronavirus why if you're in the
government would you want to get it yeah
I wasn't well you did say that why would
you why would you want to get in the
world
hack and Pierce and it wasn't a it
wasn't a Serial adulterer or a Pierce
and so if you're going to play the moral
Guardian I think
I'm asking
simply asking you if we look at them I'm
simply asking you a question
come on here I'm asking you a question
I'm here making childish jokes about
make the Grinch yeah and you talk to you
whether you think you're right absolute
disgrace to get people you're like a 16
year old you said you wanted Boris
Johnson
virus
well I'm not I'm not in the room I'm
gone I'm not there Mick Lynch hasn't
said that but you were suspended and
that shows an attitude
it shows an attitude of Mind well back
to yours back to your serial adultery
Pierce which has been well documented
back to the allegations of phone tapping
who you declare the moral Guardian I'm
not the one leading this country into a
crisis
you and your team well neither am I and
the clue the clue is
for people before the ex we know you
know you like to play what a boundary
I'm simply asking you what does it say
about the State of Mind of people
running these unions if you were
suspended by the rmt but literally
wishing Boris Johnson to die of
coronavirus I'm simply asking you
whether you think that is the right way
for unions but there there we go
well I don't think it's right that the
highly paid
um reporters such as yourself seriously
all right you're not going to answer the
questions thank you very much
try answering a few questions next time
yourself coming next is the palace
braces itself the next installment of
Harry and Megan's Netflix series I'll
talk to the reality star who had a fling
with Prince Harry and said she didn't
recognize the party Prince she once knew
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook and census.com
tonight should we be boycotting
Tchaikovsky just because it's Russia
I'll talk to the Ukrainian culture
Minister who says the Western boy can
all Russian culture until the end of the
war but first The juven Duchess of
Montecito said they've never had an
opportunity to tell their story until
they're 88 million dollar Netflix series
and if that isn't enough there's also
Prince Harry's automography spare or
spare me as we've renamed it to look
forward to next month well far from not
having the opportunity to tell their
story I don't think anywhere else in
history has had more opportunities than
these have done each time for vast
amounts of cash but how accurate is
their truth well a reality star from The
Real Housewives of DC cat ominay who
claims she well actually did have a
Fleetwood Prince Harry doesn't claim it
I think it was true so she's been
whitewashed from history and doesn't
recognize the party Prince she once knew
cat joins me now along with royal
correspondent Vanity Fair Katie Nichol
and Fox News contributor Heraldo Rivera
welcome to you to this uh Stellar panel
I must say hey um and thank you Geraldo
for joining us from across I'll come to
you in a moment cat I want to talk to
you because this book is coming out
spare is supposed to be Harry's story
but I suspect we're going to get a very
sanitized version of anything which is
awkward for him and it'll just be more
of what we've been seeing now for the
last year and a half which is just
constant attacks on his family and the
media
oh a total snooze Fest right I mean you
know the the title I love the title
thing is a great title but you know how
much he's influenced about how he wrote
it and what's in it who knows you were
34 when you met a young 21 year old
Harry yeah so a bit of a Madonna
situation going on there
really well she likes the toy boy isn't
she well yeah yeah I was criticized
because I didn't really care about age
you had a little fling with him uh it
was well documented and got pictures of
you there what was he like then as a
young guy
just really really really funny total
gentleman totally down to earth normal
and did he carry any of this enormous
baggage which he now appears to have all
the time because he seems just
completely miserable
he did at the time
but it seems business now he just seems
completely miserable all the time this
Freedom he saw it doesn't seem to make
it yeah I mean what I saw with him at
the time he was desperately searching
for freedom and and privacy
and yet what he's done is completely
turned the whole situation
full circle right and now he's got no
privacy and no Freedom well they invade
their own privacy every 10 minutes
that's the sort of irony of this
position I mean Katie we've talked a lot
about this um and the reason we keep
talking about it is because on Thursday
there'll be another dump yeah of three
more episodes in this Netflix snooze
Fest which a lot of it is very boring
you said wait for it well yeah it is
boring actually it's very self-indulgent
very narcissistic but in the middle of
all this there will be more barbs we
know at the royal family and the media
you know and they'll play the oppressed
victims well it's really interesting
hearing cat say that actually because I
think when you look at those pictures of
Harry party and I started my career as a
royal correspondent because I ended up
at a party with Prince Harry and you
know drinking bottle of vodka and having
a great time and he seemed like a very
fun guy but it's interesting hearing you
say that he seemed like someone that
sort of wanted to hide away from from
the media wanted to have his private
life and I think that is the massive
contradiction in in all of this but as I
unpick his his complaints and this
resentment and it's bitterness at the
heart of this is bitterness about the
institution bitterness about how he's
portrayed in the media and I think now
that he's actually named William in this
latest trailer and I think clearly
William and Kate and and the sussex's
relationship with William Kate is going
to come under scrutiny I think there's a
lot of sibling rivalry at the heart was
I think Harry and the fact this book is
called spare has resented being the
spare for a long time and I think we're
going to hear much more on that
particularly I agree with you um Geraldo
across the pond
um it seems to me a lot of Americans are
as fed up with them as we are I think
you're still hanging in there as being
not necessarily a fulsome supporter but
a more tolerant uh Observer of all this
what do you make of it all
well first of all I want to say I
thought of you appears when hurricane
missed that shot I really I felt very
bad for you and for uh for England uh
thank you you know in terms of the the
Netflix uh documentary and Harriet and
Megan uh you know in their participation
and you know their their ongoing soap
opera I really do feel for them and I
think that the vitriol being heaped on
them the the scorn is so snobby and
snotty it's having absolutely the
opposite effect I believe that they are
generating some sympathy now not because
of what they're doing on the Netflix
show as much as a reaction to the
British tabloids and this incessant uh
constant uh you know criticism there is
no doubt in my mind that they are they
are telling the basic truth maybe
there's a you know a shot here that
should not have been used a stock
footage a footage of photograph
photographers and so forth but I think
the general truth emerges they seem
sincere they seem beleaguered they seems
you are one of the people I most respect
in American television news you're a
hard-bitten journalist you're a war
correspondent and you've fallen for this
Guff with these two Hook Line and Sinker
because they're the least sincere people
I've ever met in my life
she's playing a role
she's a good actress my brother I told
you peers I told you how I followed
Prince Harry into Helmut Province yeah
in Afghanistan and how the American
Marines there and the British Personnel
that were still there after he had left
all all considered his service there to
be honorable even here no question so I
come as a reward correspondent I come
with that bias here's a guy who served
his country honorably put his own life
on the line he married a woman who for
the first time in British royal history
was of mixed race so the issue of racism
and here Harry's girl Straight Outta
Compton and all that kind of baloney
they have been assailed uh you know I
feel for them because they have been
targeted in a way that I feel is very
very unfair yeah I would argue okay but
I would argue they haven't been targeted
in the way that I think a lot of
Americans have been led to believe they
were targeted there was no racism to
towards them in the mainstream media in
this country there wasn't the papers
here were euphoric about this The Daily
Mail the Daily Mail just did 20 pages on
the Netflix document 20 Pages
these two sought freedom and privacy in
America and all they've done since they
got there is Cash in on their Royal
titles afforded to them by an
institution they despise and are trying
to ruin and they're making hundreds of
millions
in Afghanistan my my brother served in
Iraq and Afghanistan right and in fact
my brother-in-law taught William and
Harry at Santa's Military Academy so I I
absolutely respect his military service
but if my brother notwithstanding his
heroic War record in Iraq and
Afghanistan went on National Television
every 10 minutes dumping all over my
family that would be a very short
conversation next time I saw him you
just don't do that kind of thing to
families well you know there where is
the kindness where is the where is that
activity when here you have a here you
have a young couple trying to find their
way an extraordinary situations with
scrutiny that is that is so absolutely
intrusive they don't have a moment to
breathe now he is the spare he is the
the one that was designated to take over
when you know I understand all that and
I understand the frustration of that I
mean uh theoretically but I really do
believe that you are your lack of
kindness to them is laid bare peers you
can't have such a visceral uh
viciousness towards
he's just trying to pave their way in
the world where's the irony my response
to them is driven by their serial
unkindness and viciousness to the royal
family and their deliberate attempts now
to not only attack their family who is a
beloved family in this country but to
actually destabilize and potentially
bring down the British Monarchy and as a
monarchist who loves the Royal factors
down the British Monarchy they they will
not how why what I'll tell you why
because they're constant centuries-old
Institute because they're constant
framing of the royal family is a bunch
of nasty callous racists is beginning to
hit home in America it's hitting home in
the Commonwealth people are believing
this they're not producing any actual
evidence to support the racism claims
all the other mental health the
headlight the headline literally read
Harry's new girl almost Straight Outta
Compton right come on peers come
for your viewers not familiar with this
area of Los Angeles is like Harlem in
New York there's a lot of nice places
I thought that was an unfortunate
headline but the piece of the company
that was euphorically praiseworthy and
the truth is she comes from an area
about five six miles from Compton and
Compton produced as far as the British
audience is concerned produced Serena
and Venus Williams so they wouldn't see
it in a particularly negative way and
they think oh that's the best even
making your even all right even speaking
of Serena and Venus you you put it in a
racial context here here She is a mixed
race actress you know who's not has no
familiarity she wasn't debriefed by
Sarah Ferguson as far as I know or by
really anybody who who could guide her
into the intricacies the
etiquette and so forth she was hung out
well he can't advise knew what Harry can
do but he's a guy he's it's not like she
didn't have someone say here's how you
curtsy she didn't have someone to say
eventually
hang on they love them
you're believing the [ __ ] she
literally got given a massive dossier
explaining all these things it's now
been revealed most of what they say in
this Netflix thing is completely
understand Queen's lady in waiting
it seems to me that you have an anger
inside you that I don't know what the
source of it is but I think that for
example to to allege without proof that
this couple is a is imperiling the
British Monarchy is a grotesque
overstatement I don't think it is
historic significance yeah I don't I for
because of what because of what because
do you deny played any role
in the way that they were treated
specifically the allegations of racism
against the royal family for which they
produce zero evidence all they've done
is smear the entire family
well I think that I I think that this
was a great lesson for the for not not
just the British people and the
Commonwealth but here in the United
States a great lesson in the need for
sensitivity uh in the need for to have a
when you have a progressive step like
this that for the country to embrace
them I think that Harry would like
nothing better than to go and to help
the I heard you were talking with the
labor leaders earlier about the unrest
and the economic difficulties yeah I'm
positive Harry and Megan would like to
be part of a yeah
they've got no interest in helping in
the cost of living crisis over here
you've drunk the Sussex Kool-Aid
I I think that if you gave them a CH if
the if the reception had been a bit more
understanding if if you had a little bit
more positive of a fair Shake we
couldn't have been more people every
time how do you feel how do you you and
I have had our own uh Adventures over
our long public lives how would you feel
if every day you woke up every single
tabloid in the country was tearing you
apart it was scrutinous
that was uh actually the coverage was
incredibly positive I remember it well
yeah until it wasn't appears the
narrative did change
I rather you'd be brilliant as always as
a guest I love the way you speak your
mind I love the way you never compromise
when you have a belief about something I
appreciate you joining the show thank
you very much all right let's get a
reaction to it I just want to make a lot
of Americans by the way will agree with
their own they do they do but the
narrative did change but it didn't just
change because newspaper ready to sat
there saying right now let's put the
knife in no it changed because their
behavior changes
they became very hypocritical preaching
about the environment using private jets
preaching about poverty throwing half a
million dollar baby showers and by the
way they've made some pretty damaging
allegations in this of the trailers
anything to go by I mean the idea that
you know the palace were briefing
against them what I know from my
experience covering this beat for a long
time that their press aides were doing
everything they could to keep those
negative stories out and you know they
were so that's a there's there's
potentially quite damaging allegations
in all of this and you know Geraldo
mentioned proof well are we going to see
any proof are we going to see any others
we're not um what are your thoughts now
maybe you bumped into Harry what would
you say to him
I just didn't know whether I'd actually
even recognize him anymore
I mean I've changed so much I mean
personality wise
because when I watched him like with the
show
I just thought wow it's almost like
and my mother will really hate me for
saying this
but it's almost like she's got like a
spell over him and
um that's why I don't recognize him
because he used to be saved like down to
earth and normal and and it's only so
little of him I've actually recognized
you know Joanna Lumley has come out with
an interview with the times in which she
says that she's horrified by the way she
talks about women specifically but I
think it can extend to men as well that
you can become too much of a victim you
start to celebrate victimhood you lose
the strength and she believes that this
generation is losing the strength of
previous generations she was talking
about women but I think it applies to
men as well that there's an almost a
celebration of playing a victim right
but I mean he
it would never in a million years have
um back in those days have ever been
that person to do the show no I mean
looking at the front pages you've got up
here this is the coverage of when they
got engaged it couldn't have been more
euphoric same for the wedding they had
18 months of great press coverage they
got a lot of attention because they're
the biggest stars in the country when
you marry into the royal family anyway
we'll leave it there there's lots of
different views we'll have all these
views on Piers Morgan on census that's
the whole point of the show is that we
will invite people to have different
views to mine and to challenge mine
that's great
um doesn't mean I'm wrong
thank you both very much indeed for
coming in still ahead The Nutcrackers
among the most popular ballet music ever
written but Ukraine's calling on us to
boycott Russian components like until
this war is over is that right we'll
discuss this with the Ukrainian culture
Minister next
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
culture Minister about what he wants us
to do which is to stop playing music by
Tchaikovsky and other great Russian
musicians because he feels that that is
a way of punishing Vladimir Putin I
don't agree and I'll say that to you
when I speak to him I think it's the
wrong way to respond but it's a good
debate but in the meantime over here
Cambridge Dictionary has been accused of
Cowtown to woke activists today after
updated his definition of woman to
include anyone who identifies as female
well I'm joined by talk TV presenter
Richard Tyson I believe identifies still
as male and told to be contributed Paul
herone Adrian who I'm fairly sure still
identifies as a woman I do Paula what is
a woman
I didn't think it was that complicated a
question right for me a woman is me so I
was born female with female genitalia I
can give birth and I know that some
women can't so I'm not necessarily
suggesting that that is a part of the
Bible there's somebody who puts their
hand up and says I identify as female a
woman because that's what the dictionary
is now defining a woman to also mean
yeah and this is where I I start to
struggle with when we
talk about feelings as opposed to
defining words and this is where I feel
that the dictionary is full and foul of
the difference I mean you're not anyone
who's getting confused by this this is
some of the world's most important
people look at this a woman can have a
penis
look I'm not but
I don't think we can conduct this debate
with
you know sorry no no it's just no no I
just can you provide a definition for
the word woman
can I provide a definition no yeah
I can't
you can't
not in this context I'm not a biology
that woman who can't say what a woman is
is now a woman on the Supreme Court of
the United States one of the most
powerful people in the world Richard's
eyes it just feels to me like the world
has gone completely mad when women feel
too paralyzed to be able to actually
enunciate what they believe a woman is
for fear of the retribution that may
come their way well there's that but the
whole point of a dictionary is that you
can rely on it to give you the accurate
truth right that's literally the
function right if you're not sure you go
to the dictionary and the dictionary
gives you the truth so for a dictionary
to adopt the latest fashion the latest
trend for fear of upsetting people I
actually think is really serious I think
it's it's much bigger than this I
actually think that they shouldn't be
allowed to get away with this I think
the government should actually look at
injuncting to stop this nonsense one
thing you can be sure of is this
wouldn't be happening in Florida under
the governor's ship of Rhonda Center
running away with the popularity exactly
but it is true he wouldn't he wouldn't
he wouldn't accept this he may not
accept this and you know to an extent
you and I agree when we're looking at a
definition of what is something then we
look at that thing what we don't do is
then attribute a monologue in terms of
the ideology behind that thing we
describe that thing we Define that thing
and I don't think that that's what the
dictionary has done here what it's done
is it's it's talking about an ideology
it's talking about a thought process
about a feeling it's not saying what it
is but unfortunately facts don't care
about feelings I'm sorry they just don't
it's a bit like Meghan Markle and her
truth it's like there's no such thing as
well there's no such thing as my truth
there's the truth there are facts and
then there are people's feelings about
facts but that they're not facts well
you're right to say that there is my
truth and there is your truth I accept
that and you're right to say that well
only one of them is the actual truth no
that that's not always the case that is
the case no that's not always well
there's more than one form of the truth
of course there is give me an example
give me an example well how do you how
do you define what a woman is
is a woman born to a female biological
body boom
but that's a different
due to what a scientist might have to uh
to somebody who is what the dictionary
until this week always said a woman one
was somebody born to a female biological
body there are two Sexes male and female
that's it the whole point of a
dictionary is that it doesn't have
feelings it doesn't get confused right
now we have a dictionary it is
right but now they're endorsing feelings
right I feel like I did this on Good
Morning Britain was we had somebody on
trying to defend the BBC educating kids
of 12 that there are over a hundred
genders including astragender which is
an affinity with the stars and planets
so I said fine by that criteria if we
can identify as anything we like I am a
two-spirit penguin because I walk a bit
like a penguin I have the same
carnivorous diet as a penguin I think
penguins are much beloved figures in
this country again a big tick in the box
so I had a lot of affinity with penguins
and I like to have various Spirits so
I'm a two-spirit penguin all hell
brought loose how dare you mock
self-identity see how dare you say
you're a two-spirit penguin and I said I
am an astragender because I look at the
stars and planets and feel all woozy
that would be the BBC's way of educating
kids about what they can identify as it
is nonsense it is nonsense to you yes
to most people falling most people I'm
not I'm not sure that's right because
you know we haven't counted what what
we're talking about and what I think you
have to accept peers and the people who
want to shout at me and want to use the
word woke as as as some kind of dirty
word is you're not listening to those
people won't used to be an awareness of
Social and racial Injustice
no no what workers become for most of
the wokies is a form of fascism where
they think if if anyone disagrees with
them when they come out with this
nonsense about what a woman is for
example they must be abused shamed
canceled driven out of their jobs and
terrorized as we saw with JK Rowling who
I don't even like by the way she's
always been damn rude to me but on this
she's right but why are you attributing
the title of woke activists to those
people they're purely because they
identify normally identify in their in
their Twitter biography as woke and also
hashtag be kind they are the least kind
people in the history of planet Earth
they're vicious they're nasty they're
fascist the very thing they like to
pretend they hate most that is what they
are they want to basically indoctrinate
everyone to agree with everything they
say that's it I'm not gonna disagree
with you on that note we'll go back to a
little commercial break because Paula
Ryan has finally agreed that I'm right
about everything after the break should
we be boycotting Tchaikovsky because
he's Russian a lot for a Ukraine
Minister called for the Western boycott
all Russian culture to the end of the
war we'll discuss that after that
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Arts this evening Ukraine's cultures
Minister uh unfortunately we've got
technical issues with him he's in Paris
I think and we can't actually get the
lineup so we're going to take this
debate if we don't get in tonight we're
getting back on tomorrow
um Richard and Paula it's an interesting
debate this he's come out very strongly
read a big piece in the guardian uh
Alexander kochenko he's Ukraine's
culture Minister calling for all music
by Tchaikovsky to be paused saying that
Putin sees Russian culture as a tool and
even a weapon to attack liberal values
and has indeed of course destroyed many
monuments of Ukrainian arts and culture
I feel uncomfortable about this I've got
to be honest I don't think it's the
right response you can understand why
he's saying it why he feels it so deeply
and passionately but I don't think it is
the right response and the truth is it's
not actually going to achieve anything
what we've really got to focus on is I
think actually what we've been doing
pretty well which is giving them the the
arms the weapons uh to fight like like
absolute Trojans but but I understand
his his angst with frankly anything with
the name Russian the sense of Russian
and so you see why he's amazing we've
heard this about sport you know and they
have been punished the Russians they
weren't allowed to compete at Wimbledon
for example
um is there a difference between Sport
and cultural you know arts for example
is there a difference ideologically
between a boycott of sport compared to
gigosky I can I can understand why
you're uncomfortable but I have to
disagree with you because what we're
looking at is the absolute desecration
of not only a country and its people but
that include its culture and all right
let me ask you a question
so when we illegally invaded Iraq in
2003 this country
okay and we were with the Americans with
the correct response have been to that
illegal Invasion which is what I believe
it was which led to the slaughter of a
million people
would it have been correct then to have
boycotted all the music of The Beatles
and all the music of Elvis Presley as a
punishment and if not what's the
difference I could have understood if
that's what the Iraqi people chose to do
they come out and said if if an Iraqi
leader come out and said the world must
boycott The Beatles and Elvis Presley
what would the reaction have been I I
could have understood that peers that's
my answer of course if I can tell you
what they're actually going to be
everyone would have said forget it well
they may well so there's a bit like all
the double standards over the uh Qatar
World Cup there's a moral hypocrisy I
think at Bay here right but there's a
big difference because if you talk about
current sporting teams current sporting
uh personalities as opposed to someone
from from way back in history so I think
that for me is is the dividing line
between the two you've got you've got
what's going on currently and that
sanctions and that's Karen boycotts but
actually
um making a sort of a gesture against uh
the historical well died 60 odd years
before Putin was even born I mean this
country the country still makes money
from this and that's what this is about
Richard it's a about making money it's
interesting my mother just messaged me
completely randomly it wasn't expected
us at all she went to see a ballet uh
The Nutcracker with with a Ukrainian
woman and her daughter this week and she
said she did cringe a bit when it was
Darcy bustle apparently introduced it it
was a battle that obviously came from
Russia uh raving about the fact that
he'd come from Russia it did great with
her and maybe that is what a lot of
people feel maybe people do feel you
know what actually if Putin's
desecrating art throughout the Ukraine
destroying theaters Banning people from
doing what they love then why should we
celebrate any form of Russian culture
until this is over I do understand and I
don't really agree with the argument
because I think it sets a very weird
president which we didn't adopt
ourselves but we can take McDonald's out
of Russia we can take Nike out of Russia
then surely we should be taking
Tchaikovsky you mentioned all right you
mentioned food you just got time for
Brooklyn Beckham's latest cooking
lessons of American television this is
where he does a I think it's a junior
and cucumber sandwich here's Brooklyn
Beckham
so what he gets he gets a bit of raw
tuna he puts a bit of stuff on it
he gets some bit of egg he gets some uh
cucumber puts it in some sesame seeds
and then he puts it in a pan
and he calls himself a chef now it's a
bit like identifying as a woman if
you're not born to a female body he
might identify as a chef but this is the
kind of thing I knock up when I'm on my
owner home and I'm not a chef am I right
no I mean it appears come on you just
sound bitter now this is he's a good
Chef I I think he's a young man who is
trying his best to help if he wasn't
called Brooklyn Beckham would he be
doing his tuna cucumber special on
American television but that's like
saying if my dad wasn't a famous
journalist should I become a journalist
peers we all want to be able to follow
in the footsteps of our parents Richard
he's trying but come on I mean you know
what he's trying actually you can leave
it there he's trying good to see you
both thank you both very much that's it
from me uh Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you